is it it episode 1 you talk about Mick
Jagger oh yeah that a true now that's
true that's just again some of the
stories are true and now this is a true
story that I was there's about a
Christmas and a bit ago I was at a party
in a house and he was there and I'd met
him before at something so he came over
nice chattin we and he's a remarkable
man he's 73 but he I think I might say
he's as thin and wiry as anything but he
has got energy it's like in cocoon you
know when that light has energy
emanating from him it's remarkable and
we talked and it was all nice and then
my wife and I were leaving I'm down the
stairs in the first floor and was her
head into the door I heard Rob Rob and I
looked at one and he was on the on the
landing anyway don't try to those bloody
Spears at me they looked at me and don't
throw those bloody Spears at me yeah all
right I have no idea
I was thinking what is going on
in the age race i realize before he's
doing Michael Caine in Zulu giving me on
the trip too much so I will just so I
went I've told you before if you're not
gonna sing I don't want a bloody now now
get back in the other room
[Applause]
[Music]